hello everyone and welcome back to round
7 coverage of the 2019 Croatia
Grantchester well you know the special
guests
Henry Carlsen the father of Magnus
Carlsen to be sure Henrik welcome to the
show
thank you we know you are maybe your
son's greatest fan along with his mom
what is it like watching him play an
individual game have you gotten used to
the nerves seeing your son in battle
well I mean I was a bit nervous already
when he played the under 11 20 years ago
but I guess it's been a gradual
development where the importance of the
game have developed while I've also
become slightly used to it so now it's
for the World Championship matches that
pretty tense but otherwise I'm coping
well I think excellent you have
developed in different ways as you
mentioned there was a time when he was
winning everything a few years ago maybe
five or six years ago then he had a bit
of a lull
but now Magnus is back and look looking
even stronger than ever what what
happened well if we go back to the last
period when he was doing so well I think
it took us some time to appreciate how
much everything had been working
together for him really that he had to
kind of be extremely focused and
determined not by discipline just by
sheer will and interest and enthusiasm
in each and every game and at the same
time play with low shell shoulders and
kind of draw upon the intuition he had
practice so much that at home without
thinking about the outcome of the game
so and in addition to that he was quite
supportive he was a happy young man in
every respect so I mean I think I could
mention a lot of factors that all really
pulled together and then if there are
one or two of these that are a little
bit out of sync then it's difficult to
perform at your kind of theoretical
which I think the - probably did five
six years ago close to is at at that
time theoretical max and now kind I
think he's gradually understood what it
takes and he can now his so focused
determined to show his best and it's
been a gradual development now over the
last twelve months or so we've been
gradually kind of getting closer to to
where he wants to be it's of course
extremely difficult to maintain this but
also over the last year things have been
working together the factors have been
working together so that I think already
back in the World Championship match he
played quite well it's just that he was
up against a formidable and extremely
well-prepared opponent so it was such a
tough match that's a great explanation
best i've heard from anyone and you
should know there's something about the
human side of magnets a lot of people
see him as a professional player or we
interview him and he has to maintain a
certain facade I'm curious about the
human side is it anything that you are
the family members might see magnets do
and you think okay people think he's the
people know of him as the best player in
the world the world champion straight
genius and were like how did he do that
well you know there's plenty of things
but I'm not going to tell you
[Laughter]
you did tell me a story that I could
probably quite funny I think the fans
are going to find interesting is about
your own feeling that maybe you couldn't
have you could work really hard and
become a strong player and Magnussen is
and his is ii had a little bit of a
reaction to that yeah i mean i think
okay my wife is very down to earth she
is here as well keeping us all down to
earth in a way but i'm also considered a
fairly level-headed guy from what i
understand but the situation you
mentioned I mean I clearly need the
reality check because they talked about
what it would take for a kind of a
genius
in his twenties to reach the top in
chess and some people thought maybe 10
years of full full focus we do the we do
the trick well - and Peter I know in
your 20s it's too late I mean come on
this is it takes a lot and I said at
some point well I mean even I could
become a demon or an iron if I spent ten
years full time and that was the mission
of my life and I looked at that didn't
draw too much enthusiasm either so maybe
I should be happy to be kind of not
excess too serious and play the
coffeehouse and it's funny when your son
is put in your place final question for
you
do you ever project looking ahead how
he'll do or do you just let him be like
he's now the man that he is and however
he does in tournaments that it's his job
now not yours to worry about I think I
used to say that at least for 15 years
he's
and well above anything I could expect
or hope for us a father so I mean these
bonuses has kept coming and I shouldn't
turn out expectations I mean it's just I
love to be there and support him if he
wants to but it's his chest and of
course I shouldn't have ambitions on his
behalf
wonderful dad you have been clearly
raising an extraordinary son thanks very
much for joining us thank you
Henry Carlson the dad Henry Carson the
dad of one magnus carlsen clearly and
mother and family doing have done a
fantastic job
thank you very quick question for
Hendrick I absolutely love with
documentary on Magnus called Magnus it's
refreshing because Hollywood always
depicts chess players as nerds and it
was a great documentary Hendrik if I
could get your thoughts on the
documentary and did Magnus liked it so
yesterday about the documentary that was
done on Magnus and he really enjoyed it
he's wondering what your take was on it
and did Magnus himself enjoy the
documentary the documentary Magnus that
was that I think he it wasn't as bad as
he had feared but I think you wily went
to into it with open eyes and if maybe
not enthusiastic he kind of gradually
felt that it was giving too much of
himself so and I think that's the case
for everyone you don't want to kind of
show your inner innermost feelings to
the broader world to a certain extent so
in that sense he he was not hundred
percent comfortable with it but I think
the result is ok